now that harvey's getting bigger it's
turning into more
of a friendship
[Music]
celie loves her milk too that story
about an unlikely friendship between
a cow rescued during hurricane harvey
and a pit pitbull
found on a roadside has gotten more than
16 million
hits on youtube it's one of thousands
posted by
the dodo the top producer of animal
videos on the web
racking up 5 billion views a month by
sharing tales of animal advocacy
perseverance and unlikely friendships
when it comes to animal videos he is a
total goofball
no one out does the dodo
it's really become a movement that
people like to share these stories with
their friends to bring happiness to
their friends and also to tell them
this is this is who i am i love animals
katie brink is the executive editor of
the dodo
nicole hendrickson is senior director of
social media
when people ask us who our audience is
it's everyone that loves animals
it transcends age gender politics
background culture it's just do you love
animals and do you want to watch this
video that's going to give you a really
deep
happy feeling and feel inspired the dodo
website was created in 2014
its founder izzy lehrer the daughter of
media executive ken lehrer
when he was found he was on the streets
wanted to combine
animal advocacy and
met my entertainment they just hit it
off its first success was in the
blogging space
but in year two a move to video
and an emphasis on social media changed
everything
i remember we had a party when we hit a
million facebook fans when we were in
the office
and now we're over 30 million there was
this white space in social media before
the dodo where it was either just
pure fluff or there were the more heavy
kind of guilt-inducing
nothing that really combined
entertaining and shareable and
heartwarming and just
making you feel something really deeply
and that's what our goal is
a message that resonates with animal
lovers like me
who failed at remaining unbiased when it
came to the foster pitbull nala
they brought on our shoot this is the
best story
oh ever girl he is super sweet and very
loving
the dodo's video content comes from
around the world
a combination of submissions and their
own social media searches
it's rare for the dodo to pay for
content
with most individuals or organizations
welcoming the spotlight
i mean is there a formula to telling the
story or it just depends on the story
it really depends on the story they
bonded really well but the
thing that's always been a constant is
having that emotional connection with
the animal
usually eye contact with the animal we
love animals with really expressive
faces
you know whether it's funny or
heart-wrenching or whatever
it's got to end with a really positive
ending
an ending that kind of makes you feel
like everything is going to be okay and
there's order in the world
the dodo also looks for animal agency
animals driving the action
real life situations instead of staged
videos
a sweet spot for creating buzz
i put my hand down and she more or less
crawled onto it right away
a video we did a couple years ago about
a woman's friendship with a bee
you were kidding yeah soul mates it got
over 100 million views
a b a b an older british lady found
an injured bee in her garden oh is that
good
and she brought her in and she just she
narrated the whole thing in this very
soothing voice she'd crawl all over me
she would snuggle into my hand and sleep
and people just went wild for the story
and couldn't get enough of it
in 2018 the dodo expanded with its first
tv show
dodo heroes now there's also a netflix
kids show
izzy's koala world a kid's channel on
youtube
and el dodo it's spanish content arm
and the videos that started it all have
also expanded with more than a dozen
titled series like
best animal friends and pity nation all
helping the dodo not only grow its
audience but also educate
and inspire one of my favorite reader
emails we ever got was someone who said
that they
were scared of pit bulls until they
watched pity nation and then they ended
up actually adopting a pit bull
which is just so incredible that you
know someone would come that far so all
the puppies
had found their home and while the
dodo's content and the emotions
it conjures aims for that positive
impact
there are some unavoidable job hazards
in creating it
i've seen pretty much all of my
co-workers cry we're back in the office
we're all just kind of sitting behind
our computers with with tears rolling
down our faces
how do you do what you do and literally
not every day call
and rescue and save and bring more
animals home i think everyone at the
dodo
walks the walk and rescues as many
animals as they can a couple years ago
nicole and i
rescued a squirrel together when we're
in the office we have a little dog park
we have a lot more dogs now than we did
a couple years ago kovid has
kept those pets and the dodo's staff
home where's your mommy
but it's also kept them busier than ever
before
no stores are open with monthly views
at an all-time high of 5 billion
so many people proactively seek us out
during these times of kind of
distress and with covet and election
cycles they just want to feel hopeful
and
inspired and we show them that there's
good in the world no matter what yeah i
think that people
you know really deliberately come to the
dodo to escape the divisiveness that's
going on
on social media and you'll see
commenters actually kind of
chastise each other if they start
getting political or getting off topic
you know
hey this is my safe space i'm here to
enjoy animals and that's really what we
want to give people
happy space happy space i do want to
point out nala that that pity
she's still up for adoption i'll post on
my social media if you're interested but
it is amazing the good and the joy that
going down the dodo rabbit hole can
bring
awesome